The jogan Experience here's something
that's interesting I really think within
our lifetimes if it hasn't happened
already governments are going to start
using AI to do uh low-level
legislation um and now I'm just like I'm
summarizing in a very op optimistic way
we've been talking about this a lot
actually oh okay okay good so I got a
friend of mine Dr Allen D Thompson um if
you don't know about him just check him
out he's a he's an AI expert researcher
he's an explainer he has a thing called
the memo that comes out I think like
every two weeks something like that but
it gives you this a really holistic
State of the Union of AI and he's hyper
optimistic and calls it human evolution
which I believe in that as well if it's
used well uh you get rid of the
emotional factor and you just have
something that's looking to solve
problems yeah you know and so I think
like it can at least give you five
solutions that are non emotionally based
that are just addressed that are
supposed to kind of maximize the uh
positive probable outcome and I think we
may see a human AI uh synergistic
government low at least low-level
government imple implementation probably
some country that's like can do that and
not feel like they're Bing the farm on
it and if they if it goes well then
other people will implement it exactly
yeah I think so we were we were talking
about a AI president yeah that you need
a president that is immune to bias
corruption influence and someone who
just looks at things rationally and in
an intelligent way that spans all the
disciplines right like how could any
president really be an expert in foreign
policy the environment economics social
justice uh
infrastructure uh
immigration it's not possible how could
one person really know the correct
solution to all those issues even if
you're briefed look I can't imagine I
all I do is run a podcast and do comedy
and occasionally commentate on fights
and all those three things take up so
much of my time my whole day
today has been having conversations with
people about replacement opponents
because there's a UFC coming on in two
weeks oh wow so I've been having all
these conversations with experts and
people that I know and commentators of
who can fit this spot and who who's
ready and who's in shape and who's
turned the fight down
and how could anybody that's not that's
so minor that's my my my role is so
small I have so little to do and yet
it's it takes up so much of my time how
could
anyone manage all of those things they
can't but AI could yeah and AI doesn't
have a son that gets money from barisma
I know I know it's like the thing about
I know well it's like I mean if you look
at like there's it's really hard I I had
I had a term I don't know if it exists
but I call it corpor corpor crats and
most people in government essentially
are corpor crats in in the sense that
the things that when I see people like
vetoing things or not getting on board
with certain things and you're like well
that seems like that would be helpful
but you're choosing not to do that it's
like the influence of Corporations on
even well intentioned you know people
that go into government and they're like
I want to make a difference I want it
just gets in there it's it's baked in
there and so I don't know how you're
going to you're going to overcome that
the only thing I can think of is like
because my thing is like I'm not really
political in the sense that I don't have
a party I'm pretty independent I'm just
like I want to choose people that
are that are humble enough that have
enough humility to work with anybody
that's that wants to solve a problem
that they're that they're wanting to
solve and to Sol and to create solutions
for the most amount of people Poss
that's kind of that's all I'm looking
for because there is no excuse for any
of us being all the inequity we see in
all the all the stuff is totally
solvable if we were much more efficient
with uh how how well how resources are
utilized how they're distributed and so
forth